problema 1 al tiempo de la posición de
una partícula que se mueve en el plano
xy es x de t 7 donde x de tdt no están
dadas de manera explícita para t mayor o
igual que 0 la derivada de x con
respecto a t es igual a 4 temas 1 y la
derivada de jake con respecto a t es
igual al seno de t cuadrada en el tiempo
te iguala 0 x de 0 es igual a cero y de
cero es igual a menos 4 vamos con el
problema a encuentra la rapidez de la
partícula en el tiempo te iguala 3 y
encuentra el vector aceleración de la
partícula en el tiempo te iguala 3
primero recordemos que la rapidez de una
partícula es la magnitud del vector
velocidad así que cuál es el vector
velocidad como función del tiempo pues
será la derivada de la posición en x con
respecto al tiempo o podríamos decir la
velocidad horizontal multiplicado por el
vector unitario y más la velocidad
vertical multiplicado por el rector
j escribí esto en términos ingenieriles
pero hay muchas formas de especificar
vectores y en este caso x prima de t es
lo mismo que de equis dt que nos dieron
aquí y es exactamente 4 esto que está
aquí es 4 t más 1 por el vector unitario
y y para prima de t también nos dieron
la información y dejen de t es igual al
seno de t al cuadrado por el vector
unitario j
así que este es nuestro vector velocidad
nuestro vector velocidad en función del
tiempo veamos cuál es el vector
velocidad al tiempo igual a 3 pues sólo
tenemos que sustituir para t igual a 3
así que ponemos que el vector velocidad
en 3 pues va a ser cuatro veces tres más
uno es 13 13 y más 3 al cuadrado es 9
que será el seno de 9 jota y la rapidez
que es lo que nos están pidiendo pues va
a ser la rapidez debería decir en el
tiempo igual a 3 va a ser la rapidez va
a ser la magnitud de la velocidad el
vector velocidad en el tiempo 3 que es
igual a la magnitud de 13 y más el seno
de 9 j y para calcular esta magnitud
utilizamos el teorema de pitágoras pues
en esencia esa es la forma de calcular
la magnitud
y esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 13
al cuadrado que 169 más el seno de 9 al
cuadrado
y voy a traer mi calculadora en este
momento del examen nos permiten traer
calculadoras y así que vamos a escribir
la raíz de 169 más el seno
el seno de 9 al cuadrado muy bien esto
es 3 al cuadrado más el seno de 9 al
cuadrado y obtenemos 13.00 mejor lo voy
a redondear a 007 si se ve que no nos
dio un 13 exacto y que el seno de 9 pues
contribuyó en algo así que la respuesta
a la pregunta
es igual a 13.00 7 eso es lo que nos
están preguntando para la pregunta y
después nos preguntan por el vector
aceleración de la partícula en el tiempo
igual a 3 y el vector aceleración de la
partícula pues va a ser la segunda
derivada de la posición con respecto al
tiempo o sea la aceleración horizontal
por el vector i
más la segunda derivada de la posición
vertical con respecto al tiempo por el
vector jota o sea la aceleración
vertical la segunda derivada de x dt
pues será la derivada de la primera
derivada esta que tenemos aquí así que
si es cuatro temas uno la segunda
derivada va a ser simplemente cuatro por
iu y la en la componente vertical
tenemos que aplicar la regla de la
cadena entonces va a ser la derivada de
t cuadrada que es 2 t que multiplica a
la derivada de seno que es coseno de t
cuadrada y tenemos a j en su lugar esta
derivada la hicimos la derivada de t
cuadrada con respecto a t es 2 t y la
derivada de seno de t cuadrada con
respecto a t cuadrada es coseno de t
cuadrada entonces ya tenemos el vector
aceleración en función del tiempo pero
no lo están preguntando en particular
para él
igual a 3 así que analicemos este 4 va a
quedar igual y de este lado tendremos
dos veces 3 por el coseno de 9 a ver
déjame escribirlo esto va a ser 4 y
y de este lado vamos a tener dos por
tres que es igual a seis por el coseno
de nueve a ver vamos a escribirlo aquí
arriba que sería seis por el coseno de
nueve por jota y ahora vamos a usar la
calculadora porque bueno siempre nos
dejan usar la calculadora en estos
exámenes y vamos a tener que seis veces
el coseno de nueve nos va a dar un
resultado como menos 5.46 bueno lo vamos
a aproximar y entonces este resultado
tengo otros que estoy haciendo si se es
jota no esté a ok nos va a quedar a
menos 5.46 7-j otra vez lo escribí en
notación ingenieril pero se podría
utilizar otro tipo de notación y creo
que las personas que realizan los
exámenes lo aceptarían pero podríamos
utilizar la notación parametrizado de
vectores o la de parejas ordenadas lo
podríamos escribir como que el vector
aceleración en el tiempo 3
4 - 5.467 al final están diciendo lo
mismo
esta es la componente x del vector y
esta es la componente del vector